chào các bạn video này sẽ hướng dẫn
chúng ta các cái thao tác trên đối tượng
table chúng ta
sẽ tạo cái đối tượng table như bên trái
màn hình và bây giờ chúng ta sẽ bắt đầu
cái việc mà tạo bạn và nhập dữ liệu vào
á thì thao tác đó chúng ta
sẽ vào Insert chọn table và chúng ta sẽ
ra chuột để xác định kích cỡ của bạn Sau
đó nhấp chuột và chúng ta nhập vào giống
như ở bên phải bằng hình và sau khi nhập
vào chúng ta thực hiện một vài các thao
tác à định dạng để hoàn chỉnh cái tro
này và bây giờ cái thao tác đầu tiên đó
là thao tác thêm cột và xóa cột thì
chúng ta quan sát bên bên trái màn hình
là cột đầu tiên á là không phải là số
thứ tự mà là đi trong nước và tiếp đó
mới đến số thứ tử như vậy chúng ta phải
thêm cái cột ngoài cùng bên trái và cái
cột thứ ba cột cột thứ hai trống này này
thì chúng ta phải xóa đi vì nó thừa à
thì thao tác thc khiện như thế này thêm
cột chúng ta đặt trỏ vào nha Chúng ta
đặt trỏ vào vị trí Cần thêm cột chúng ta
vào cái thẻ table layout chúng ta chèn
cột thì chúng ta chọn Insert l hoặc
Insert right chèn bên trái thì chúng ta
chọn Insert left chúng ta nhắc chuột
chúng ta chọn có cột bên trái đó là thao
tác chèn cột còn cột này á cột thứ ba
này nó đang thừa chúng ta đặt trọ vào
chúng ta vào table layout chúng ta chọn
delete và chúng ta chọn Delete column
xóa cột
đấy bây giờ số thứ tự này chúng ta đặt
vào vị trí cho đúng của nó là ngoài cùng
ô ngoài cùng góc trên bên trái rồi tiếp
tục bây giờ chúng ta sẽ thêm dòng Xóa
dòng ở cái bảng bên trái màn hình này có
vị trí là dòng thứ ba nhỏ này chuyển
tiền đi ngân hàng khác bản bên này nó
thiếu thì chúng ta sẽ bổ sung để chèn
thêm dòng thì chúng ta có thể ra chuột
bên ngoài bên trái này chúng ta khi nào
có dấu cộng thì chúng ta sẽ nhắc chuột
vào để kèn kèn dòng và có thể có cách
khác là chúng ta vào table layout chúng
ta chọn là
Insert about hoặc Insert below Insert
about là chàn trên dòng ở trên vị trí
của trọ Insert below là chèn ở dòng dưới
vị trí của trọ ví dụ chúng ta chèn là
Insert below chèn dòng như vậy cái bảng
này chúng ta chèn thêm hai
dòng nhưng thực sự ra là chúng ta chỉ
cần một dòng thôi nha Chúng ta Xóa dòng
này đi Xóa dòng này thì chúng ta sẽ vào
là table layout chúng ta chọn lệnh là
delete và chúng ta chọn là Delete ground
Xóa dòng rồi và bây giờ chúng ta phải bổ
sung vào đây là ba nhỏ và gõ vào đây là
chuyển tiền đi ngân hàng
khác rồi và tiếp tục đó là thao tác thêm
dòng xó dòng nha bây giờ thao tác nối O
và chia O thì ví dụ ở đây chúng ta quan
sát số thứ tự ở bên bảng bên trái này
thì nó nằm trên 4 ô chúng ta phải nối
lại 4 ô thành 1 quét chọn 4 ô ha chúng
ta vào thẻ table layout chúng ta chúng
ta chọn lệnh là m s đây nổi 4 ô thành 1
tương tự như vậy khoảng mục chúng ta
chọn 2 ô chúng ta chọn m s và cách khác
thì chúng ta nhấp phải vào và chúng ta
chọn m
sell đó và tiếp tục thao tác chia ô là
như thế nào Ví dụ ở dưới này dưới này
này mục
à đến trong nước này phần này chúng ta
nối này nhưng mà
ô bên này này thì có cái mục có vị trí
để gõ vào là 1 2 ở đây lại nối mất rồi
cho nên chúng ta đặt không rõ vào chúng
chúng ta vào table layout chúng ta chọn
split Cell chia o chúng ta nhắc chuột
vào và nó sẽ xuất hiện này number of
column là chia thành bao nhiêu cột
number of round chia thành bao nhiêu
dòng thì chúng ta sẽ chia
thành một cột và hai
dòng chúng ta chọn Ok đây chia thành một
cột như hai dòng ở vị trí này chúng ta
sẽ gõ vào con số 1 và vị trí dưới này
chúng ta gõ vào con số 2 đó là thao tác
nối ô và chia O thì tiếp theo là canh lề
chúng ta chọn dòng tiêu đề này chúng ta
vào table layout chúng ta chọn canh lề
là canh giữa chúng ta chọn align center
còn những kiểu kiểu canh khác thì chúng
ta quan sát và chúng ta
chọn
đấy tiếp theo
là chúng ta sẽ nối cái ô ở cái bài bên
trái này là đi trong nước là từ số 1 mà
đến con số 4 là các ô này được nối lại
với nhau và gõ vào là đi trong nước thì
chúng ta quét chọn nhắp phải vào chọn m
c và chúng ta gõ vào là đi trong
nước và mặc định Thông thường thì khi
chúng ta gõ dữ liệu vào thì dữ liệu nó
nằm ngang cái bài bên trái là chữ đi
trong nước nó ghi dọc lại này thì để
thực hiện thao tác này chúng ta thực
hiện định dạng đó thay đổi hướng dữ liệu
chúng ta đặt một trỏ vào chúng ta vào
thẻ table layout và chúng ta chọn lệnh
test
Direction test Direction nhấp chuột vào
đây nó dịch chuyển À cái cái hướng và
nhắp thêm một lần nữa giống như trong
bài và chúng ta chọn canh giữa
đây tương tự dưới này chúng ta cũng gõ
vào là đến trong
nước và tiếp tục chúng ta thay đổi hướng
dữ liệu thì chúng ta lại vào là test
Direction đấy và canh giữa thì chúng ta
nhập vào align Center
đấy tiếp tục là chúng ta sẽ tiến hành là
định dạng cái bảng này thì chúng ta định
dạng cái màu sắc giống như bên bên trái
này này thì chúng ta có thể tự mình chọn
cái định dạng bằng cách là chúng ta vào
table design chúng ta chọn Border chúng
ta chọn shing hoặc chúng ta vào thẻ home
chúng ta chọn Lệ Border đây và chọn
Border Sing hai cách nha Có thể là chúng
ta làm cách khác là chúng ta sẽ dựa vào
cái định dạng có sẵn của guộc đó là
chúng ta vào table design và trong khung
là table size chúng ta nhắc vào vào cái
nụ table siz đây chúng ta chọn kiểu đây
Chọn
kiểu được Chưa chúng ta nhắc chột vào
chọn đây khi nhắp vào chọn thì một số
cái nội dung chúng ta cần phải hiệu
chỉnh lại ví dụ như cái tiêu đề nó trở
lại như cái định dạng của cái Style này
và chúng ta sửa lại chúng ta chọn chúng
ta chọn setting màu nền của nó chọn màu
nền và tiếp tục là chúng ta chọn table
layout chúng ta chọn canh giữa lại
và chúng ta cái khung là cái đường ở
giữa này là màu trắng thì chúng ta sẽ
vào là table design hoặc là thẻ home đều
được nha chọn tiếp
là size Border à chúng ta chọn Border
chúng ta chọn tiếp là Border and shing
và sau đó là cái đường ở giữa này là
chúng ta nhắc chuột chúng ta bỏ
đi chúng ta sẽ chọn
đường đơn và chọn màu trắng và chúng ta
vẽ đường ở giữa đây và chọn Ok đây chúng
ta hoàn tắt cái thao tác là tạo bản còn
những những dòng chữ này chúng ta sửa
lại định dạng chữ màu trắng thì vào home
chọn định dạng màu sắc cho cái chữ đó
màu trắng rồi tiếp tục và chúng ta kiểm
tra xem nội dung nào cần hiệu chỉnh nữa
thì chúng ta hiệu chỉnh còn chúng ta sẽ
ho tắc Ví dụ ở đây tiêu đề chúng ta cần
phải làm cái tiêu đề nữa chúng ta chọn
vào cái test effect chúng ta chọn kiểu
tăng siz lên và canh giữa như vậy chúng
ta hoàn tất còn bên này nữa biểu phí
dịch vụ chúng ta chọn BN ô này ba ô này
chúng ta nối nhấp phải vào chọn m s rồi
và chúng ta kiểm tra đây về mặt cơ bản
hoàn tắ đy Đó là các cái thao tác chúng
ta hoàn thiện cái đối tượng table và
video này đến đây kết thúc x ch chào các
bạn